in 1995 the great carl sagan wrote a  fantastic book that i've been  recommending to people for years called  the demon haunted world science as a  candle in the dark the idea the the idea  being that science and empiricism and  thinking and rationality  are a candle in what would otherwise be  a very dark circumstance and there is a  quote from the book that has now gone  viral which starts with i have a  foreboding of an america in my  children's or grandchildren's time  when the united states is a service and  information economy and he goes on from  there and the critique that 27 years ago  he preemptively made of this sort of  non-thinking  dark ages way of moving in the united  states it has unfortunately come  completely true thanks to the republican  party read the book if you've read it  let me know in the comments what you  think make sure you're subscribed to my  youtube channel as well